[Music]
the last three chapters of the tombs of
ottawa ursula kayla green's second earth
sea novel
focus on the escape of tenar and ged
from first the tombs of ottawa and then
ottawa itself towards a open future
that is kind of scary for tenar and
which ged is trying to get them to come
along on it involves choices that 10r
makes to not be arha any longer the
eaten one but to
be who she's becoming
and there's a lot of
drama involved in this and we can say
that there's really three
different escapes going on one very
localized one a bit broader having to do
with the entire island of ottawa
and then the escape from the kargish
lands themselves
to
the archipelago or the inner lands as
they they are called by the cargs so the
first escape really you could say begins
at the moment where they decide that
they're going to trust each other arha
chooses to be tenar
and chooses that to take on this story
and this you know involves some
resources there's a great passage where
ged says you have knowledge i have skill
meaning the skill of wizardry we have
the restored ring of ereth akba
and we have this thing that built
between us that we can call trust
although it goes by many names those are
our resources
and we have to deal with the nameless
ones
ghett is holding back the anger of the
nameless ones it's been draining him
this entire time it also restricts him
from being able to do
everything that that a mage would in
fact be able to do now that he has his
staff back
and um
they they have to make their way through
the labyrinth arja or tenar knows the
paths that they have to take how to get
there
god can hold back these nameless ones
the old powers of the earth and use
wizardry for other things as we're going
to see
it's not clear what the ring is actually
doing for them but the trust thing is
incredibly important now they face manan
the eunuch and ged ends up striking him
with his staff
more or less out of surprise manan falls
into the pit he could have been somebody
opposing this uh in part because he
doesn't want arja
who he's the last person to actually
call tenar before ged shows up he loves
her and he doesn't want her to go right
and then there's this uh
sort of
progress to get to the trap door
and what we find is here is the passage
they came to the passage beneath the
hall climbed the stairs came to the last
steps up in the trap door at their head
it was shut as she always left it she
pressed the spring that opened it did
not open
it's broken she said it's locked he came
up past her and put his back against the
trap it did not move
it's not locked but held down by
something heavy can you open it perhaps
i think she'll be waiting there has she
men with her
dubi and uato may be other wardens men
cannot come here those are other eunuchs
and ged says i can't make a spell of
opening and hold off the people waiting
up there and withstand the will of the
darkness all at one time
we must try the other door then the door
and the rocks by which i came in she
knows it can't be opened from within she
knows arja says or tenor says she let me
try it once then she may discount it
come come tener so they they go to it
and
already the anger of the
old powers of the earth is manifesting
itself there's a shaking that is going
on uh the the stone steps hummed and
shivered as if a great bowl string were
being plucked in the depths of them and
he says come come uh they know that
we're here and then he says then let
them know that we're here and he he
makes great light within the under tomb
and then bursts the door asunder and
they they get out
what happens after that well the anger
of the nameless ones manifests itself
in the earthquake that destroys the
tombs of ottawa they're actually sliding
down
into the ground and castle and her her
accomplices are no doubt killed
in this and they managed to
get away
she looked from the horror of the
earthquake to the man beside her whose
face she'd never seen by daylight you
held it back she said in her voice pipe
like the wind in a reed after that
mighty bellowing and crying of the earth
you held back the earthquake the anger
of the dark
we must go on he said i am tired i am
cold and so this leads us into the
second thing which is in the chapter
11 the western mountains they go up into
the mountains
they don't have a lot of tools they
don't have food
but they do have each other and actually
tenner says man i wish we could stay
here forever and get says well if that's
really really what you want
we can in fact
stay
and they they talk a while get is trying
to recover from all of the things that
have been happening
and
ged says let's let's walk and they
stop in a grove of of trees
they divide a piece of bread and the
last crumbling bit of cheese for
breakfast
and then went on by evening they were up
high in the mountains they camped in a
valley of another stream where there was
plenty of wood build up a sturdy fire of
logs tenar was happy she'd found a
squirrel's cache of nuts exposed by the
falling of a hollow tree a couple of
pounds of fine walnuts and a smooth
shelled kind that ged called uber
she says i wish we could stay here i
like this place and god says you know i
grew up in the mountains myself
and they they talk some more and then
they go down
to
they travel over the the mountains
together and they
travel to a village before that god puts
on a magical disguise for them why
because ged is a dark man and everybody
on the kargish isles are you know lily
white and they will they will know him
for one of those evil sorcerers that
they've heard of from the inner lands
and so he disguises them by magic
as um two peasants and they go to
a village and ged says i think i'll ask
for a bite of supper if i see a kindly
face they left the village next morning
with full stomachs after a pleasant
sleep in a hay loft and he says you know
i think hospitality is a very great
thing
i also reciprocated although we didn't
tell them of course that i healed their
goats who had infected udders and then
they go to a large town
as we find out it's built of clay brick
walled around in the carrickish fashion
with overhanging battlements watchtowers
at the four corners in a single gate
they spend some time there
and then they they move on as well so
this is their second escape they're
trying to get to the place where ged
actually has his boat by the sea
the third escape is actually to get the
boat into the waters
and sail away and this is
the most you could say most harrowing
for
tenor because you know getting out of
the tombs she's dealing with an enemy
and castle
and the nameless ones who she's you know
essentially committed sacrilege against
that's a matter of of life and death the
second escape you know going through the
mountains going down through the village
in the town to find ged's boat that is
getting them to a point where something
can happen
the third is leaving the island that she
has never left
going somewhere
new not only new as in perhaps going to
one of the other
three kargish islands
but leaving her entire
culture her people her religion
all of that behind
starting a new story
with ged who she doesn't really know at
the start of the chapter chapter 12
whether she can in fact trust as she did
in the tombs
and they come to a resolution and they
manage to truly escape and this escape
is not only an escape from an island not
only an escape from a culture
it's an escape from the influence
of these old powers of the earth
of her past of the evil that she has as
ged says been a vessel for
and an escape not just from
but an escape towards an escape
into
something new offering greater
possibilities
for her and for ged and indeed since she
bears the ring the restored ring of
ereth ekba
for all of earthsea
you